take a look at this one from Yahoo
sports
Damar Hamlin has cardiac arrest on the
field NFL suspends game versus the
Bengals you may have seen this but what
you may not have seen is I will play you
this clip from CNN of Sanjay Gupta let's
see will the uh is the audio gonna play
throughout the body the goal is to
restart the heart and it sounds like
that they were able to do that on the
field most likely with a defibrillator
applying electricity to the heart to
restart that and then also we learned
from Adrian I believe she said earlier
that he continues to be in critical
condition which we knew but stabilized
overnight which is obviously important
so hoping for updates what I've just
described is a rare situation again I I
had actually never seen it happen
certainly not you know a film the way
that it was you know for for frankly the
world to see but that seems like the
most okay Sanjay Gupta says I've never
seen it
either he is a terrible doctor
or something really messed up is going
on now I I okay I know guys guys he
could be both all right it could be both
that he's a terrible doctor and
something bad is happening I get it I
get it everybody yelled at the mix I
said that I was like either he's a
terrible doctor or something mess-up's
happening but let me point this out he
said I've never seen this last night on
the football field uh Damar he he's got
the guy you know I don't know who the
other guy was running at him I'm not a
big football guy he tackles them they
spin hit the ground he stands up then he
passes out
so you want to look up what people are
calling it like committee oh yeah I got
that it's commercial Cordis commercial
quartus okay Latin for agitation of the
heart okay so they're arguing it's this
rare thing where your heart gets hit
right at the right moment causing some
kind of fibrillation which disrupts your
heart or whatever
Sanjay Gupta on CNN said I've never seen
it before
really you've never seen it before take
a loose
here this is um
airtable.com this was posted on Twitter
by died suddenly I am not making any
assertions as to what's causing any of
this nor does this table but homeboy
Gupta wants to go on TV and say I've
never seen this before
take a look at this list you want to
start counting here's a 21 year old guy
in Greece February 3rd 2022 heart attack
dies here's a 29 year old pro athlete
heart a sudden expected death here you
go here's people who have heart issues
didn't die this person said it says they
died but they didn't write death on it
every time you see a red bar that's
death so let's just scroll down let's
just scroll down look at all this those
are deaths these are athletes who are
having direct issues with related to
their heart respiratory system or
they're just dying it is not an
assertion about vaccines I want to make
sure that's clear because I tweeted
about Demar 24 years old cardiac arrest
and then immediately some dudes like you
would love for this to be the vaccine
and I'm like what like I didn't even
bring that up why are you bringing that
up why are you associate I'm just saying
24 will have a heart attack that's crazy
yeah all I said was Cardiac Arrest 24
years old you have this air airtable.com
all of it has sources WPXI here you go
23 year old hockey player sudden
Unexpected death hockey player for
California University of Pennsylvania
died unexpectedly over the weekend
there's no it's not clear what led to
his death a whole bunch of these death
you want you want to see how long this
list is let me let me let me scroll down
start counting I I can't even I can't
look it's it's so massive here we go
we're two-thirds of the way through yeah
the dates are all 20 21 and 2022. now
look I'll say this I went through this
list randomly clicking links and the
stories exist I can't speak for every
single Post in here I don't know what I
know is I pulled up like 10 or 15 and
the stories are real these people all
died somehow for some reason I don't
know why so when Sanjay Gupta says this
of Demar I've never seen anything like
it bro are you reading the news because
this list is nuts look how it's still
going still going this got this there's
got to be thousands thousands of
affected people there was another post
by Dr Peter McCullough is Peter McCall's
name I'm getting ready yes he said that
they did the study and found 50 1580 or
some odd heart related issues among
athletes of that one thousand uh 101
deaths in the past was a year I think it
was
prior to this 1 100 people had died in
the past 38 years here's my question
I have two questions what's causing it I
know a lot of people want to jump to
conclusions whatever those conclusions
may be and the other question is why is
it that so many people on social media
are assuming immediately it's the
vaccine
I know it's causing it it's climate
change
clearly no obviously that's what the
corporate media has been telling us
listen here it could also be racism
could also be video games
racism yeah that's a good point yes
absolutely I think that's racist just
saying that
you're talking to a person of color
watch out here no no hey sorry Ian are
you trying to give Luke a heart attack
yeah well come on seriously all right
to be funny but people we were talking
about people Sanjay Gupta has his head
in the sand literally and to to blame
what happened here on on speculation is
something that the corporate media has
been doing there there was a post by a
Chris haddock who is claiming to be a
physician and he's blaming this this hit
on the heart of a tackle this one in a
200 million chance of of him getting hit
at the right time but right right where
the heart was was beating at this
perfect time that that stopped his heart
for for money that's real it does happen
it is real but it's one in 200 million
and the people spec regulating this this
Chris haddock guy wrote hey this is
what's Happening Here totally
speculating here because he doesn't know
we still don't know what's going on here
we still don't know the medical history
we don't know if this person did take
the vaccine or didn't take the vaccine
okay it's not fair to speculate but he's
speculating and then he's calling people
who are also speculating terrible and
horrible people you're doing what well
you're accusing people of doing what
you're doing so so made a good point
they said these are just a famous ones
exactly these are these are people who
are on teams where their deaths are
noticeable and so it's even high school
college and professional sports now look
look D2 D3 uh especially high school
what about the ones that we don't hear
about that that we we of course know is
happening as well we don't know what's
causing this and what I mean by that is
a lot of people have assumptions a lot
of people are making predictions a lot
of people are looking for patterns but
I'm saying definitively we need an
investigation into this right now Sanjay
Gupta may have been saying I've never
seen it happen like he knows it happens
but he's never seen it and he mentions
being filmed that way but that's not how
like I'm not going to give him the
benefit of the doubt I'm not going to
sit here and try and justify what he's
saying he's like I've never seen it
before typically when someone says that
they don't mean physically see it they
mean like like hear of it happening or
or witnessing like an event or reading a
chart or something like this two things
to break down here uh another thing that
I also brought up a couple months ago on
the show was specifically insurance
companies coming out and raising the
alarms about excess deaths especially
when it comes to males between the ages
of 18 and 35 talking about how there was
an alarming rate of young people dying
more than they ever have before two
What's Happening Here we don't know
because the government is standing in
the way from any kind of transparency
any kind of accountability any kind of
of data collection when it comes to
seeing what's actually going on here the
government is denying all of this as
they're still selling a product so if
there was some transparency if there was
some accountability like the government
of Florida is actually doing right now
which their Surgeon General came out and
said that there actually is a a
correlation between the two if we had
any of that we would have some trust we
wouldn't be speculating what's going on
here but because Bill Gates intervened
and told Donald Trump not to investigate
not to collect the data about what was
happening with the Trump scene Donald
Trump didn't have this investigation we
don't know what's going on here and
they're hiding the numbers they're
fudging the data and the data that's
coming out in other countries like the
United Kingdom is absolutely worrying
and is showing a picture that is worth
questioning and debating and and is
Connecting the Dots here let me let me
tell you what gives me pause
I I post this this story Cardiac Arrest
24 years old
and haters come out and say immediately
it's not the vaccine and I'm kind of
like why why are you bringing it up
here's what I think I think there are
people
who got vaccinated and got boosted
who personally inside themselves believe
something is wrong
and they assume the vaccine's causing it
but they don't want it to be true
because they fear for their own health
that's why they're coming out
immediately like no no but the reason I
bring that up is because I didn't even
say it this could be caused by coven
this could be caused by cardiovascular
damage caused by covet from people who
went untreated one of one of the
symptoms of covid one of the one of the
problems was lung scarring and what I
can't remember who we had on it might
have been Joe letipo from Florida
we were told that the spike protein of
covid Damages the microvascular system
in the body causing problems with
oxygenation of the blood it it also does
cause blood clotting I'm not saying
definitively that's what caused it I'm
not a doctor my point is how come these
people this guy didn't immediately
respond with I think covid is is causing
these deaths it makes the most sense no
the immediate thing he says is no no not
the vaccine and it's like
I don't think you just just one really
quick point you also get the spike
protein not just from covet but you also
get it from the vaccine for covet as
well which is an important note to
mention sorry go ahead and I think you
don't have to jump to conclusions to
come to the conclusion that this is not
normal like a bunch of 20 year old kids
who are healthy otherwise healthy
randomly dying is not normal and that is
something that warrants questions it's
something that warrants an investigation
like you said and if you don't agree
with that then you are living again in
this Blissful ignorance or maybe dare I
say it's a lot more nefarious than just
Blissful ignorance I
um you're right it's not normal man and
last night on Monday Night Football in
front of the world like I think a lot of
people around the world are have heard
about the myocarditis from the Vex the
conversation about vaccines myocarditis
and they're thinking okay whatever
conspiracy will wait on that yeah they
just saw a guy fall down on Monday night
TV and a lot of I think awoke a lot of
people or shook a lot of people into
into thinking more about you know what
the hell is happening right right right
right the answer to the question of why
why are people assuming it's the vaccine
the answer that question may be because
there's a lot of people on social media
who are saying this there's
documentaries like died suddenly and
then you mentioned regular people don't
think anything of it until they see a
dude suffer from you know cardiac arrest
on the field and then you know it's it's
the opposite of outside out of mind they
see it so they associate it but here's
the point I want to make I don't care
for for making an assertion as to what
causes this I don't care for that
whatever you want to believe you're
entitled to believe I'm just going to
say this as always find a doctor you
know and trust as it pertains to this
airtable.com link with all of these
people who are injuring injured or dying
from heart issues
what we start we start with is we take
all of these stories We Begin
investigating these stories we've seen
data that suggests it is abnormal and
there is access mortality mortality
then we investigate these to find common
causes we do a legitimate investigation
and draw the conclusion after the fact
we don't say hey look a bunch of people
are dying I'm going to immediately
assume it's this no no hold on you're
allowed to do that but I think for the
sake of solving the problem waking up
normies and and making sure more people
don't die
we don't need to make assertions we just
actually do the investigation yeah but
the government at the same time is
saying no shut up no investigations
nothing is happening here black is white
don't don't pay attention to what's
really going on here don't pay attention
to the huge amount of excess debts here
you got nothing to worry about just keep
complying just keep taking them which is
absolutely crazy my point which is
spurring on the these theories and I
agree with you if we want to wake up
regular people who are being lied to or
or being gaslit the government's saying
nothing to see here folks okay well
there's something to see here we just
don't know what it is we got to
investigate in whatever way we can if we
had a good government and a healthy
Society the response to all of this
should have been hey this is really
tragic we should all learn how to do CPR
and let's wait to find out what's going
on here but we don't have a good
government we have a corrupted
government that has been bought off and
paid for by big Pharma that is doing
their bidding that is giving them no
liability liability and is going along
with their studies that they fudged that
they manipulated and pushing a product
that we still have no long-term studies
on that's that's that's that's a lot of
questions I think deserve to be answered
I'm not a medical professional I'm not
telling people here what to do but at
the same time hey my conclusion from all
of this is is you should be asking
questions uh it's not it's not terrible
to be asking questions the people who
are trying to Gaslight you are some of
the people that are speculating and
trying to literally conjure up climate
change in order to excuse a lot of this
nonsense which is absolutely crazy
delusional kind of thinking when clearly
there's a lot of evidence there's a lot
of coincidences provided to us it's fair
to make those conclusions and at the end
of the day if we're left to win anything
from here is like hey learn how to do
CPR a lot of places a lot of communities
do it for free it's worth doing I had to
give someone CPR I once saved someone's
life giving someone CPR
um and um I can't recommend it enough if
you guys get the chance to to learn
learn it do it please immediately
because there's going to be more of
these cases coming uh very very soon and
so all all of your points though it's
like it should be just as alarming if
not equally so as the fact that all of
these people are dying suddenly that
people don't want to even let you do
what you described right look into
patterns look into consistencies and it
literally goes just to the shirt that
you're wearing if it's it's not science
if you can't question it it's propaganda
and so genuinely like why is there such
a resistance for people just to know the
truth to know if there is a pattern if
there isn't that's okay we're okay with
being disproven we're not actually even
making the assertion there's nothing to
disprove we just want facts we want
truth but also too there's just seems to
be like so much resistance to it which I
think should concern everyone like why
would you even ban a documentary like
died suddenly from the internet if there
wasn't something there I don't know well
the censorship you know it's it's the
Game of Thrones quote from Tyrion
Lannister when you cut on cut out a
Man's Tongue you don't prove him wrong
you only prove you fear what he has to
say yeah and according to the CEO of one
America a National Life Insurance
Corporation he's talking about how
there's an excess debts of 40 percent in
the third quarter of 2021 that are not
related to covid specifically among the
ages between of 18 through 64. what's
causing a 40 increase in excess debts
that's a question worth asking
especially when the data is clear that
it's not related to covid what's going
on here it it's something that should be
worrying a lot of people it should be
something that we should be having
debates and conversations on it should
be something that the corporate media
should be focusing on but of course
they're telling you just sweep it under
the rug don't worry about it and because
of that this is one reason why we have
to hold them responsible for this and
why they might be culpable in all of
this especially with all the big Pharma
money that they're taking from Pfizer
and other large multinational
corporations that previously bribed
regulators and doctors in the media in
order to of course gain profit and screw
everyone else over which they have a
record in history of doing someone
saying it's uh the list is 304 Adverse
Events that are that are listed in this
but these are all news cited stories
yeah so this is you know articles were
written and published that people could
then reference to so one of the weird
things about this story right now that
we're talking about with Demar getting
or hitting that guy and whatever you
know you know what happened is that the
NFL canceled the game in the middle of
the game it's the first time in history
well since 1933 I'm reading about it
that uh ever for an injury as a game
been canceled that's what I thought was
crazy it's so weird and then the every
team in the NFL changed their Twitter
profile their profile to Demars Jersey
like there's like there's some sort of
guilt Collective guilt what do they do
to this I think getting canceled in the
game right I don't think that any player
on that team could have played that game
and in in any good faith or an ability
with what had happened
um you know but what happened it is
unprecedented you know but look we'll
know soon hopefully I've I've seen
people taken off the field in stretchers
before I've seen people get knocked out
and like go limp but the game wasn't
canceled yeah this is it like evosh
tweeted something he's a leftist he's
like oh no a football player got injured
on the field must be something fishy and
I'm like
yeah bro we got Ninja on the field and
they shut the game down everyone's had a
crime I'm like I don't know I'm not a
big football guy I've watched a lot of
games I've seen a lot of injuries I've
watched videos where like bass there was
one it wasn't like a basketball player
recently hit his head and get knocked
out and they it was like a huge shock
they kept playing
yeah people people get injured and
someone else comes in yeah I think I
think I've never seen an injury where
they actually have an ambulance come on
to the field and take someone out in
that way I think that was probably what
was jarring to a lot of people similar
to the way you said people that weren't
thinking about this Cardiac Arrest stuff
or anything like that they this was like
something that made it front of mind for
them and I think it just speaks to how
catastrophic it really was to watch like
I've seen some crazy injuries like in
football games and things like this but
like this like I'm probably it's one of
those memories I feel like is going to
be according the guy is still in
critical condition right now as we're
speaking um and and we're also hearing
from the chat I don't know if this is
true or not but they're saying that the
game wasn't canceled but the team said
that they refused to play yeah so so
well yeah yeah that I think it's worth
mentioning from Yahoo two hours ago uh
article comes out the NFL canceled the
game for Demar Hanlon it reads it didn't
after Chuck Hughes died on the field in
1971. so we have I don't know times
change maybe yeah true like we are in
this was the number one turning topic
like literally five minutes after it
happened we're on the show people were
like dude just collapsed I saw it in the
chat it was just dominating and everyone
was talking about it thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time